hello everyone today marks day one of my
journey my dream is to go on stage one
day and be a seeker again I'm here to
announce a brand new series on evans
channel called unlocking lily and we're
going to bring you on this journey as i
learn grow make mistakes have wins you
get to come with me and watch me conquer
my dream so i she started filming today
for my series so I really want to get
something out of the way I am NOT not
the kind of person that shares her life
with the world I am not at all I am very
private and I don't even really post
things on my social media so for me to
do this is completely stepping outside
of my comfort zone and I even told Evan
that doing this this entire thing is
actually makes me want to throw up like
physically I want to throw up so guess
what he tells me that kind of advice he
gives me our lovely Evan sends me this
voice message I'm going to let you
listen to it okay right here and then
[Applause]
[Laughter]
let me go
anything is up for upper filming so I I
really hope you guys come on this
journey with me and the reason why I am
doing this is I want as much of an
unedited version of my journey as
possible I think there's a lot of value
in that when I see someone who's very
inspiring I always look at them and see
the struggles that they went through I
tried and that gives me a lot of hope
and knowing that I could go through it
myself
when I see someone when
everything is perfect and everything is
so great it makes me feel like I can't
do it even though I know that they have
struggled as well so I really really
want you to come on this journey and see
everything as much as I can share with
you I want to in the process and the the
hardships the difficulties but also a
lot of the funny moments and and joy and
happiness as well so actually my first
assignment is today so Evan sent me an
email yesterday to do an special
recording I have done a few impressive
with Evan in the past and he usually
does happen I do the other half as well
but this is my first time guys actually
doing it completely on my own from start
to finish so I've been preparing it for
for the last couple of hours or so
evident has been doing it for a long
time and he does it super quick and it
seems super easy but for me who's
starting out it takes a lot of
preparation as well so I'm going to
actually start recording that right now
okay hope to see guys soon